what's the home life been it's great how
the face times with Nina been over the
last three weeks well we're always
together so just it's real life
face-to-face Time come on bro that's my
fiance
the last time I was on your show and by
the way thanks for having me guys I I
love you guys well it's always a good
time with the boys you're doing great
thanks uh yeah bro I wasn't uh I was
engaged now I'm engaged still you are
dude I'm [__]
I'm putting the game
dude you got these bro
okay okay okay
[Laughter]
I was dogging on you why I was talking
on you no to you to you yeah I don't
know if you remember this I was like
Andrew yo best of luck with that married
life yeah [__] dweeb yeah and you're
like you know if you find the right
woman it doesn't seem so bad and I
remember thinking this guy doesn't know
anything yeah Andrew is right I was
[__] right yeah I was right Dennis
entered the chat
is it has it has it been stressful at
all
this is a better question did you see
any Meme and you laughed a little and
then you're like wait a minute I can't
laugh
I can laugh I can I can really I can
laugh do the both of you laugh at one
yeah which one some of them are really
fun can I can I guess the one which one
the turkey one is the funniest yeah
I'll be honest they're all they're all
good they're all good the guy is [__]
so good at Twitter it is it is yeah it's
impressive no it's top tier trolley yeah
which is which is why I chose him as an
opponent you know but you didn't know it
was going to go this hard no no no no no
I had no idea um but I mean we got
people interested right at the end of
the day it's all fight promo is there a
little bit of jealousy from from Tommy
and KSI I don't I don't John was jealous
John was [__] he was Furious he
started kicking tables though yeah which
was awesome I mean it was like something
out of Shrek bro he's Game of Thrones
are the best family
[Laughter]
all right yeah John Fury is a legend of
the whole press conference was crazy I
you know Dylan hates me I don't give a
[__] about him I think he's an excellent
troll I think he's I think he's very
parasitic which is why I'm honored that
I get to be the one to like take him out
and embarrass him that's why I took the
fight I was like okay I know this guy's
gonna promote the [__] out of it people
are going to be interested because if he
shows up I get to be the one and that
that excites me and you have no question
what will happen if he shows up nah I
don't in fact can I get a drink
you know you're in New York bro yeah you
might get the Gap pulled up on you again
bro yeah he said he said
he said that last time I was here you
said it what you said that when you were
on the Pod you were like yo Mike got the
got the pistola pulled on yeah but then
he started telling people that I had to
like check in when I came to New York so
what's up after this I'm gonna wait
outside for an hour I'm gonna give him
my address I'll see if he pulls up well
don't give him a horse yeah
listen let me think about like this or
not let me just think if I like this or
not I don't I hmm he's not gonna come up
here beat up Schultz by default like no
I'm not worried about getting beat up
I'm more worried about a shooting
happening you know
I feel like the gun consequences in New
York are pretty serious they are
producing yeah it's fairly severe I just
had to slice them what the [__]
slices
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah okay all right listen listen hold
on one second so is there any stress
between you and Nina what's the Vibes
zero zero really yeah and come on
why let me ask you something why would
there be stress between us
Andrew come here
I had to make sure the legs are also
getting worked out he's trying to be
seriously
okay so no stress between you guys
[Laughter]
move I'm trying sexual Milton you better
calm the [__] down get him some tequila
okay no for real so no stress at all
I'll tell you why
uh me and Nina
are so [__] open with each other I
knew she had long-term relationships her
whole life I knew some of them were very
public yeah she's been famous for
but her entire adult life you know like
11 years she's been Paparazzi so none of
this surprised me and I know what kind
of person she is she knows what kind of
person I am and so like
dog you gotta understand at one point I
was the most hated person on the planet
like I've heard it all I've seen it all
I'm so numb to it I know who I am I know
who my girl is I know we love each other
some [__] internet troll posing as a
fighter is not gonna get between us but
it has to buy damn it so corny
but but for real that was I thought that
was good I thought that was what you did
was good just right there
believable but you
so now I feel like we have to reflect it
but I was you were like Vivek ramaswamy
showed me this guy
bro we gotta I'll be back anyway so uh
okay all right so yeah so you knew the
whole you knew everybody she dated right
dude there's like there's like five of
them well that's the the pictures if you
look they're just like repeat pictures
or half of them are also some bangers on
there what are you talking about like
some good names on there Leo's The
Impressions
but if you play football you gotta go to
Alabama
you can't be upset about it I love
Inception okay thank you no it's good
but she aged out so now she's she got
she got caught yes
what was that what is his age did she
stop at 25 or did she go over because if
she got over that's goat status right
there I don't know if she made him break
the rule
she is a goat who knows who knows I
don't know I didn't uh do my
backtracking
right now but bro these dudes what he's
done is because she's been Paparazzi
yeah for so long with like the same
three to five long-term boyfriends
he's been able to then post pictures of
her with everyone else it makes it look
as if yeah yeah because bro in all the
pictures
he's posted 170 of her by the way whoa
90 of them are either her gay friends
fans or some like modeling shoot so like
I don't know I think I think if you're
me and you're her and you know the truth
it's like oh all right I get it but if
you're someone who doesn't know her like
why and you and you don't like me
do you feel like he's gone too far or do
you respect the fight let me ask you
something
do you feel like he's gone too far
if it was my wife I would be personally
offended I wouldn't enjoy the the
experience but I'm not a public-facing
even a Thanksgiving the Thanksgiving I
would enjoy that that would be funny the
alien one too I like that one I thought
it was funny yeah it was like a big
inflatable alien I was like that's a
funny one yeah
actually I show her the alien I said did
you [__] him yeah she didn't [__] the
alien definitely not come on uh as far
as I know I don't even think aliens got
joints what do you mean like I've never
seen an alien with a joint like knee or
elbow joints no like they don't have
penises yeah they don't have they don't
have but they enjoy anal they'd be
probing a lot yeah
oh no yo you gotta ask did you ask about
that that's crazy the aliens do do that
so no but it had to bother her a little
bit because I know you're built for it
but she's not and the double standard
brother
innocent bystander third party female
who has nothing to do with this fight
other than being my fiance yeah she's
promoting the hell out of it bro you
can't do prenup after this
come on
no nothing
well you know I got primed because
I mean you know maybe it's something
no I did say to her I said Nina I gotta
be honest you're handling this [__] like
a warrior and I will compensate you
accordingly that's what I'm talking
about with my with my winnings yes you
know like like she's never experienced
like hatred in her life all of a sudden
because she's linked to me
this is my fault yeah I feel so bad but
she's she's strong as hell dude that's
like it's part of the reason like how
she's handling all of this why I chose
her to be my fiance I have stupid
standards I did my diligence I know who
this woman is I love the [__] out of her
she's she's the person who I want to be
the mother of my children her values are
in line with mine her morals are [__]
amazing I learned from her she inspires
me I could go on it all day and it's
it's green card she needs a green card
and honestly she would have got that
already I think that's why she's
settling for me
she's Danish her vicious
didn't that make sense with the nappy
bro you can hit her with the nappy yeah
nope nope
whoa [__] you you really did that [__]
shows bro
don't do it bro don't do the nut but you
don't have Prime say again you don't
have Prime you got no Prime
um what we're announcing the prime deal
once you guys sell it you're gonna give
me a piece
can you tell us that could you bleep it
out if I tell you yes promise I swear to
God my life Miles Market all right so
Terence Crawford yeah
amazing boxer like greatest right now
literally incredible yeah you probably
swear to God in my life we believe
damn so that's the price to do it no but
he's he's amazing like we're gonna
further our relationship with him he's
so [__] good yeah yeah bro we're
doing well we're doing well um okay
could you beat him no [__] no [__] no no
because last time you were a little like
no don't you beat Floyd no you might
think you could be Crawford too
boys should go to your head bro yeah you
did like that because I was watching the
first of all I do not like this brother
bickering [__] between you and Jake we
gotta put stop to that I know I did I
did I tried I said to him I said we got
to keep the [__] offline bro like I I
saw his last thing online I was
wondering if you're gonna bring it up
and like I just don't want you guys
fighting because I love Jake and I love
you and I don't want the beef and uh you
guys were having like family uh you know
squabbles in public yeah like a
Thanksgiving combo that was in front of
everybody that was crazy that was that
was a Thanksgiving combo bro yeah and
you think I would have learned from
we've just done this exact same thing
before yeah you know it's just been five
years since we had any sort of beef and
we don't have beef I just think like
I don't know what I think are you guys
very competitive I guess that's probably
what it is
we some things we see eye to eye some
things we don't we're both vocal online
in the same room we disagree I don't
know I don't know because you said it
you were like I think I'm the better
boxer you said it was that one of those
things that like you say with your
brother when you're both talking [__] so
you're both trying to take Jabs or are
you genuinely after watching him yeah
like
why are you smiling bro cause I see what
you're doing what am I doing you said it
trying to get that clickbait [__] the
clickbait I you said
you said what I'm trying to say
now where I [__] up because I can say
to Jake and to the internet I can say I
do believe I'm the better boxer ow
en yeah why do you always do that I want
him to be serious with us
bro come on
no you got Prime you got wrestling you
got everything you got the podcast one
thing like give them the boxes he's
right he's great he's way better whoa
whoa Milton Milton hold your breath
Puerto Rican Puerto Rican we good what
does that mean what does that mean come
on we family we in here
I feel like you don't [__] with me I
love you no I really do I [__] with you
way better yo way better way
okay maybe not way buddy clearly
that makes it worse
you know what I I uh I appreciate I
appreciate the honesty I really do
because because here's the other thing
I'm just sitting here running my [__]
mouth you know I haven't proven [__] I'm
all in one I'm only one yeah but
whatever bro because you don't think
that
you know what I mean you can't think
that right I don't think that and it did
hurt you a little bit when he was like
after I rewatched the fight I didn't
think you won I saw your face sunk
well just because he was he was gassing
me up the whole time he was gassing me
bro you won that [__] yes and then
all of a sudden he's like you [__]
lost [__] but now all of a sudden
a few things happen in between you
[__]
no listen
let's let's put a pin in this I love
Jake I [__] love him we decided after
we both went public with our little uh
disagreements no more public [__] nah
it's so stupid it's so [__] still
what are we doing we love each other
that's my brother why did you point it
out in the moment
um like when you guys are afterwards
like yo maybe you should just trim it
from the pot we did it was a
conversation here's the honest answer
and this is what happened in 2017 and
that's why I said we I can't believe we
haven't learned from our mistakes
because it's happened before just get
caught up bro in like the ego like no I
don't care you shoot a pod you're doing
the next thing I landed from a flight
from London three hours ago I'm here I'm
gonna work out I'm gonna go to Puerto
Rico I'm a train like it just life is go
go go go go go go go and you often don't
think about the repercussions if you're
moving so fast you just don't like
impulsive is one of the six big things I
do and I'm trying to give notes in the
chat and I'm like maybe this won't be as
big of a deal as I think what will it be
received right and it's just a lot to
think about mentally that I don't give
enough significance
you love him and he's better
Jake Jake listen to me I [__] love
you bro you're better and by the way
download better Jake's betting app on on
the App Store
download
[__] better baby micro bets all day
uh other types of bets as well and if
somebody wanted them
plus support right him like in a boxing
match what would you tell them to bet
bet on Jake I'm better Jake's download
better app there we go
Dylan says this right and he sent it to
some people he said there's a picture
that's gonna end there or whatever yeah
is it you with a guy
[Laughter]
because that's
that would end the fiancee
this whole time I've been thinking of
something regarding Nina no no bro this
makes way more sense yes remember that
time remember how much you were giggling
when I was touching your thoughts I was
[__] with it yeah oh [__] you got
like this yeah
so so
[Laughter]
we had a face to face I told you this we
sat down at a table me and Dylan yep for
30 minutes
uh no uh third-party uh conversation
happening just me and him talking and in
it he was asked about that photo and I
was like bro you know what I think
I think you're a [__] liar not just
with this with everything Dylan's a liar
he lies about everything he's a troll
that's what we do right you just say
[__] to try to trigger people it's funny
but he lies and so I was like you're
saying you have this photo
why don't you post it
post a [__] photo bro Chicago
and I said no you don't I call this
Bluff I said no you don't and even if
you did even if he did have some
grotesque derange explicit photo
this dude was dumb enough to fight
ing the photo and and transferring it
already which is a crime in itself if
he's saying he's going to go to jail for
it he's already committed a crime by
transferring this explicit like likely
non-consensual image that's already
illegal so if so if he were to leak it
or have someone else leak it like it can
always be traced he didn't send it to me
I asked though come on I didn't ask for
the photo I was like what is it about
what is it come on and he goes he goes
he goes he goes Logan's your boy I can't
send it to you and I was like well yes
but just tell me I don't want the photo
I just want to know what it's about he
knew better do you have an idea of what
it is I don't think he has a photo
now did you have a conversation with
Nina we were like yo talk to us 100
and what did she say I said
do you have any idea what he's talking
about she says no
she said she said I legitimately bottom
of my heart have no [__] clue what
he's talking about if if he has
something it's something that I don't
know about like non-consensual did you
guys have to have like tough combos
because of this or you already went
through your past because you've had it
like this too like this no this is easy
this is like this is hanging with the
boys
is is there like a version where like
she's friends with people that you might
have gutted come on don't say God
rephrase it sorry sorry she's tens of
people that you spined out can you make
it less harsh we can edit it okay so
yeah is she and is she does she know any
people that you gave them esophagus
oh my goodness because that's the thing
she's a famous [__] supermodel you
may have been with supermodels before
that might be difficult for her I'm a
[__] YouTuber
what's wrong with that yeah I ain't
[__] supermodels
come on bro you're trying you're trying
to tell us we're supposed to believe
that you've never had sex with a
supermodel before in your life I've
never had sex before man Nina
yo that I believe low gang
dude what if you start lying but it's
just gay [__] I'm a virgin dude
that's not gay yeah that's not gay it's
closer to gay than [__] women
[Music]
it's half gay
we're just being on no it's half gay yo
hmm like you haven't fully transitioned
but
you bought the the clothes